Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number that
you can call any time you want. The number is
two one nine two. David P Here is a voicemail.
It's sort of tongue in cheek, but it gets at a
very good point, which is if gas prices are thanks
to Biden. And gas prices are up everywhere. It's
all thanks to Biden, right? Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: Good afternoon, Mr. Pacman,
sir, I have a question about gas prices
knowing that obviously the gas prices are
Joe Biden's fault. I see that the gas
prices have also gone up to about $5
U.S. in Canada. Wow. And I'm just trying to figure
out what socialist policies. Sure. Brandon has
implemented into Canada to cause them to have
also very expensive gas prices, even higher gas
prices than we do here. I love to hear from you.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And of course, the caller makes
a good point, which is gas prices are
up globally. Why is it Joe Biden's fault
again? And you guys know me? I do not play these
political games with gas prices, whether it's a
Democratic president or a Republican president and
whether gas prices are up or gas prices are down.
Go look at my clips from when gas prices were low
and Obama was president. I was. Other than tongue
in cheek joking around, I was not praising Barack
Obama for lowering gas prices. American presidents
have very little that they can do. What they can
do is if they want to dip into the strategic oil
reserve. It is believed that they could pull
down gas prices by 18 to 20 cents a gallon,
and it would take a period of time for that to
happen. But of course, the caller is right. You
look around the world and you see the same thing.
How is it Joe Biden's fault again? Republicans
love, love, love doing the gas price games.
It's pathetic, but a lot of people fall for
it. We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Finally, Trump's postmaster general, Louis DeJoy,
he may be on his way out. And we'll tell you why.
Number two, New York City wants to limit the use
of various artificial intelligence tools for
hiring employees. I'll explain. And we now have
the results of that estate tax giveaway that was
part of Trump's tax plan back in 2017 that was
implemented in 2018. It dramatically reduced IRS
revenue from inheritance. It had the exact effect
that the very rich wanted it to have. We have
the full numbers and we'll talk about them on
today's bonus show. Get access to the bonus show
by signing up at joint Packman dot com. Remember
that on December 14th, 6:00 PM Eastern will be
doing the next viewer town hall on the Pacman Live
YouTube channel. Make sure you're subscribed
to that channel. We will give, of course,
priority to our website members, but everybody
will be allowed to call in everybody. Everybody
will be allowed to call in. So no one. Subscribe
to the Pacman Live YouTube channel. Number two,
if you want a much better shot of getting
on with me during our town hall, sign up
at Join Pacman NJ.com. You also will get access
to the bonus show as a member and we will see
you there in mere minutes or right back
Unidentified: here on tomorrow's show.